come on Logan bring it Brock car brah
oh nice nice spiral oh yeah i love spyro
i just i preciate guy got spiral anna i
need to go to my room and returned
warrants flash drive okay it's pretty
adamant anyway it's your boy
psychobabble here uh just um we're could
I Scott dormitory good lord Nathan's
family owns my dorm uh bench oh no bro
you can't take a picture you're gonna
wait till Friday's game how about you
[__] get ready guys get your knife
ready oh look it's max Caulfield the
selfie hold blackwell what a lame
gimmick even mark mr. Jefferson falls
for your wave hipster [__] the de
garion processor you could barely even
say that I guess you got your meds
filled oh sure that's how they cut their
up oh [__] aircars you know all the
answers I guess you have to find another
way into the dorm we ain't moving oh
wait hold that pose so original don't
worry max I'll put a vintage filter on
it right before i post it all over
social medias know why don't you go [__]
yourself e oh yes Victoria I'll get your
bony ass out of my way what a [__]
rich a nice loss sprinkler look at that
very nice let's do the rockies done uh
huh sir
oh [__] sorry I had a little headache
and it's just like track this down a
pocketknife up ok he's got this he's got
this let's say [__] let's say that
bunny hat you know it looks a gang sighs
sorry you need some help it's [__]
slow that's all you could say hey I
hurry up sir oh ok do the right thing
okay well they're doing here while he's
doing that what's in here oh this is how
we're gonna poison them I got it boys it
up this my and sprinkler valve looks
easy enough to use I got good mm-hmm I
would like to use this a tight
I must have missed something I should
rewind dad I put enough semen in there
none shall pass capisce I ask a fish
riches capisce
and is this over here no I don't [__]
did I miss nice prayer can I go throw a
football at it sweet no there's only one
way around this yes suck it up oh yeah
we go tamper even though the girls can
[__] see me tampering that's okay a
little long it's Vicki us okay let's see
if this works I don't want to mess with
that ladder in hurt pour ce o-- wanna
[__] I just wanted to get Victoria at
the hell out of the way yeah cancer
there's no yes what the hell are you
kidding look at that she'll Victoria
it's just water yeah water on my
cashmere do you know how much that's
[__] outfit cost you look great I
can't even chill on the steps oh good
gut let's get though let's get them in a
bucket of semen
uh shut no no no hey Victoria well Sammy
oh sorry wet pain is not good for hair
nope get the hell away from me weirdo
hold on hold on look at some towels
we'll be right back so move your ass
before I dry it worked don't mess with
Max [__] I can't get it's not that
semen uh-huh sariah uh hey Victoria what
do you want max comfort I am sorry
that's an awesome cashmere coat it was
but there will be another got got yeah
that's important well you always seem to
know how to pick the right outfit I do
have some talent mr. Jefferson told me
I've seen your pictures you have a great
eye Richard Avedon esque oh that's one
of my heroes thanks max I hope those
[__] get me a towel before they hang a
sign on me
uh-huh Corey deserve a better shot sorry
about blocking you and and the go [__]
yourself e that was me but pretty funny
just one of those days you know I know
exactly what you mean Victoria I'll see
you later ok Bob gut gut gut let's get
in here Victoria probably played me I
should have played her better get to my
room before I find Warren uh
Oh rad iram Oh God good I'll get my
white getting away Toria is going to be
pissed we took so long who's that dear
nice atmospheric shot needs dusting ah
this is like the public DNA of our dorm
hey LS Alison diamond funky fuckin'-a
will bang for jesus oh god get Charlie
got a snake like pushing on out oh oh
[__] Oh daddy uh-huh mr. guitar home
sweet home my favorite cocoon what's
sewing or like out if I'm not looking
through a viewfinder i'm looking through
a window always looking am I looking at
part sorry looks like Dana left me a
little post-it note great now I have to
go get the flash drive from Dana's room
you see my little fun or out lorca
dicorcia my man I don't think I could
take my camera to those places look at
that shot I love julia cameron's
Victorian vibe talk about analog cameras
ah dolly what a fantastic I he could
truly freeze time
oh thought I was gud gun right yeah five
bucks why
oh oh max & chloe best friends forever
who even says that anymore I'm going to
have to call Chloe eventually and find
out what she'll say the longer I wait
the worse it'll be idiot hi said that
today
Dennis I feel so nice to just relax I
just let it this day has been so damn
bizarre and it feels like he's gone on
forever maybe I'll just wake up now and
find out I was dreaming off this or like
posted a dream within a dream oh nice
cottage some luck on his camera is that
poster wood man ray call them selfie
portraits don't like my not exactly
pretty in pink but no shits are given I
like my wardrobe is that now yes yes
daniel has so much talent I hope nobody
hates on it just because it's me I am so
addicted to this site okay look at these
vintage beauties ah Horan makes me laugh
it's nice to feel like I already made a
real friend here good
oh [__] sorry sir what about you mama ok
mr. glant honor you are Thursday well
the worst baby mama drink up what's not
right here Lauren even left me a little
message with his flash drive he's such a
goofball Kayla Holocaust that is they
can insane living I got trashed shopping
finally right here's what books ahead is
a tall cartier-bresson do I know
Hamilton the greatest I need to live I
need to entertain as the only more gun
people you can't get out now Dina so
tell me the truth or rotten man oh [__]
what is this [__] welcome to the real
drama queens of blackwell ants are you
woof hey Juliet is everything cool oh
yes Mac I've lost Dana in the room
because we're cool you want reviewing
what you do what did she do what didn't
she do Dana's been sexting with my
boyfriend oh god I like that how did you
find out uh why do you care why are you
even asking me you never talk just zone
out with your camera that's why I'm
talking to you now what's my last name
Oh Mason uh Juliet Mason that was truly
sad thanks for your concern max
Caulfield by the way Juliet Watson okay
now I never chair and hey Juliet
oh yes massa let's get out what did she
do what didn't she do ouch uh that's why
I'm talking what's my luck what's that I
thought I was that Juliet Watson uh-huh
I'm flattered I didn't even think you
knew my name at all I know yeah there's
the gym just because I don't talk a lot
doesn't mean I don't care so how did you
find out about them according to
Victoria Dana would do anything to date
a quarterback according to Victoria huh
she saw the sex and Zachary won't answer
his phone once Dana admits it she can go
straight to hell ah where is I have to
find Victoria no need to go there now
huh
fire huh what is this looks like nobody
won this tepee war there's nothing left
but ghosts yes Oh Sally shower showers
you later sexing okay which one's I'm
okay I guess so Victoria shrimp huh is
that the best way I don't know I'm not
gonna do that notorious my pal man leave
me alone max get a clue [__] I think
we [__] do Victoria thing all right
no it's very nice camera tablet is she
going to get a 3d printer for her dorm
room maybe i will join her posse stick i
lock laptop yeah it's like luck what is
this luck thing its conjugate is only
like crazy about photography I'll give
Victoria props for not posting my photo
boom this is the email i need to show
Juliet now I have to print this fast and
get the hell out of here ok how do i
print up Brett
oh where is it where is it this better
convinced Juliet that Dana is innocent
uh-huh
it's just I don't know this is good
pocket Juliet read this of course I'm an
[__] I'm sorry Dana you are and I
hope so you really think I'd mess around
with sacra no but I get stupid jealous I
owe you dinner still love me and you do
my laundry thanks max you're like the
Blackwell ninja now let's see what zach
has to say about Victoria you set me
free thank you Warren's flash drive is
on my desk uh okay almost done get the
flash drive and then I'll go see Warren
pregnancy tests look at it that looks
like a home pregnancy test take it take
it
Oh max that's mine thank you hey you're
not helpful you're just nosy I think you
better go I needed to say that nice max
you hurt her feelings by being so damn
nosy again but I could rewind and make
it up to her take a ticket sorry must
protect my precious so max never has to
chase it down again shall use the
flashlight I better make sure everything
is still in there I think Warren forgot
to hide the party Buster folder not that
I would open it no matter how tempting I
have my self-respect ladder Oh cleavage
is hey Dana seriously thanks again I
can't believe Juliet locked me in my own
room real mature a hair right yeah what
Dana I'm not trying to be nosy but I
heard a rumor about you what who told
you I was pregnant nobody important they
just acted like it was [__] I just
wanted you to know it's like a goddamn
reality show around here can you keep
secret max yeah yeah of course of course
I was pregnant was oh oh what about the
other that beat dad you can catch him on
the 40-yard line this friday and it's
not Zachary
sorry to pry it's not my business and I
won't be at the game Friday not much
school spirit i guess i like your spirit
max anyway you better get that flash
drive so Warren has an excuse to bug you
cheer later Nick that's ok ok ok
Oh